hey guys it's Charlie so a bunch of you
are messaging me freaking out about a
Batman rumor about Ben Affleck leaving
the role so I'm gonna explain what's
going on so it was kind of in the middle
of making another video and then a bunch
of you started messaging me about this
Ben Affleck rumor so I thought it would
probably be more important that I make a
video about it just because most of you
are bigger fans of Batman than you are
of the stuff that's going on on
Supergirl so I'll just mention that at
the end of this but Ben Affleck may be
leaving the Batman role so hopefully
just to make you guys feel a little
better I'll say new round of the
injustice to give away I'm giving away
copies of the game all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video I'll announce a winner at
the end of this - for the last one in as
bad as all this Ben Affleck stuff sounds
don't worry there'll be a bunch of
prozac level videos coming later this
week between flash and everything else
just to make you feel better about life
in general but the whole reason that
people are talking about this is because
there's a reporter that says he has
sources behind the scenes that say you
know three different people you know
doesn't really name who that say that
Ben Affleck is trying to get out of his
contract with Warner Brothers to be the
Batman and be in these movies what's
your position the bat vigilante in
Gotham Daily Planet civil liberties are
being trampled on in your city good
people living in fear don't believe
everything you hear something nothing
has been confirmed nobody's come out
from the studio this is a relatively new
thing and usually when big things like
this break everybody starts reporting it
all the big news sites then people from
the studio Ben Affleck other people come
forward and say look this is what's
happening this is all bull crap we're
not gonna comment any more about it like
usually they come forward and say
something to make you feel a little bit
better or to let you know what's going
on
usually the policy of the studio is to
not comment on anything there's just
been a lot of stuff going on with this
Batman movie in the DC EU so everybody's
been going extra crazy which has led to
a lot of Ben Affleck comments being
taken out of context you know him not
being used to this crazy level of comic
book fandom don't believe everything
so worst-case scenario he stops being
Batman does the Batman movie and then
that's it they have to recast someone
else's Batman for the next time they do
Justice League or they would scrap that
and just completely replan what DC
movies are gonna look like going forward
they're always gonna make DC movies no
matter what but you have to imagine that
this is their first try at doing a
shared universe so whatever Ben Affleck
does it doesn't necessarily affect the
other actors that are doing DC movies
Jason Momoa is getting ready to start
shooting Aquaman really soon Wonder
Woman is getting ready to come out
there's still the flash movie that
they're writing right now they're
writing a new version of the script but
they're still making the flash movie so
all that stuff would still happen but
they would just replan how everything
fits together a little bit down the road
which I feel like everybody be fine with
everybody just wants good movies that's
the most important thing if it takes a
little bit longer to get it done that's
totally fine there's another Superman
movie coming that they haven't
officially started talking about because
people still think that he's dead people
that didn't stay through the end of
Batman V Superman that don't know that
he's coming back but they just announced
Green Lantern's so if Ben Affleck leaves
this is only if he actually ends up
leaving his contract and not being
Batman after the Batman movie what would
probably happen going forward is that
they would just go back to the old
system of making DC movies they would
all kind of be their own thing they
wouldn't have to interconnect Marvel
style or they would just flat out recast
Batman and he would show up for the
first time in the next Justice League
movie instead of showing up in a solo
movie so I will go on the record as
saying that I think that Ben Affleck is
a fantastic version of Batman it totally
sucks that they're having this much
problems behind the scenes so as of last
week it sounds like they're all systems
go they made that Matt Reeves
announcement on Friday night it was like
hey deals done Matt Reeves is gonna do
the Batman movie so then a little while
after that there was a report that they
have a script that they totally like
people from the trade magazines the
people that actually talked to the
studio people were saying the script is
done they're happy with it in all that's
left for us as fans is to just wait for
somebody from the studio to say okay
we're gonna start shooting on this day
and this
is what's gonna be happening they'll
start making casting announcements but
the whole idea is that they would start
production on that movie this year but
the person that was reporting all this
crazy talk was saying that I've been
wrong in the past so take it with a
grain of salt so that doesn't mean that
you should automatically start freaking
out it's just that when somebody sees
something on the Internet
they tend to believe it especially if it
comes from a website so don't worry
don't freak out
but because all this is just so crazy I
would not be surprised if in the next
couple of days somebody from Warner
Brothers came forward and said something
official about all it teether say no
this is bullcrap or this is what's
happening and this is how it's gonna go
down so even though Ben Affleck has been
a great Batman it would still be a huge
blow to DC and Warner Brothers comic
book movie plans Batman is kind of the
linchpin of their movie universe right
now he's their biggest earner he's the
character that everybody loved from
Batman V Superman so him bailing on the
universe would be one of the worst
things that could happen but there's
still a number of contingencies they
would still make DC movies they would
cast another Batman in a couple years
and they would do more Justice League
stuff it's just that it would take a lot
longer before we could go sit down in a
movie theater and watch those movies but
by all accounts you know just to make
you feel better about DC in general
there's been a lot of drama with the
Batman stuff with the Superman stuff but
Aquaman looks like it is going to kick
ass and even Wonder Woman looks like
it's going to be a vast improvement
Justice League is supposed to be the
rebirth of hope they've been using the
term rebirth a lot because DC rebirth
has been amazing for their comic-book
lines so I feel like they're also doing
that with Justice League they kind of
explained the Man of Steel to Batman V
Superman to Justice League is this
trilogy of Hope so the Empire Strikes
Back the darkest movie was there Batman
V Superman so Justice League is supposed
to be there Return of the Jedi but I
think the problem is is that nobody's
seen the trailer like we just need the
trailer and people will calm down a
little bit just to see what it actually
looks like because the test footage that
they showed off at Comic Con last year
wasn't that finished the special effects
were kind of raw so it wasn't a really
accurate picture of what the final movie
is gonna look like so don't worry even
if in like five
years Ben Affleck still isn't Batman
it's not gonna be the end of the world I
feel like people just heard that he's
trying to leave the role and they took
that to mean that there won't be
anything happening but no he would still
do the Batman movie but if you guys
haven't seen it mister mixi is Pitt look
mr. unpronounceable is guest starring on
Supergirl most of you guys don't watch
the show but I feel like if you're gonna
watch the show ever this would be the
time to do it just to see him be
ridiculous
so just to make you feel a little bit
better about life in general I'm gonna
play this montage of him from the other
TV shows that he's appeared on from
Smallville to some of the other things
[Music]
Superman are you serious yeah I'm from
out of town
the 5th dimension to be exact names
mixed yes pitlor
mr. makes yes piddling
it's not the usual way and since the
games were about to begin I thought we
should do the formal interim thing what
a riot
mr. Mixel flick I guess that depends on
what you're working for
mix let me guess want to buy a vowel mr.
mixers Pitt lick and I thought bat-mite
was a weird one don't worry I just need
to trick him into saying his name
speaking of Superman stuff if you guys
didn't hear Teri Hatcher is actually
guest starring on Supergirl - I don't do
regular videos for that but I just think
it's really cool that she's coming on
and the flash is on break this week so
I'll be doing bonus videos so don't
worry there'll be a lot of DC TV bonus
videos a lot of other Marvel stuff
coming but I'll say congratulations to
Henry Panoz you win a copy of injustice
- please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video all announced
the winner when I post my flash bonus
video tomorrow while you wait for that
you can click here for brand new flash
you can click here for my Lego Batman
Easter eggs there's a bunch of them
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five
chill out everybody it'll be okay I'll
see you in the next video